أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية. اسمي John Watrous وأنا المدير التقني للتعليم في IBM
Quantum. هذا الدرس رقم 15 في السلسلة وهو الدرس الثالث من الوحدة الرابعة التي تتناول تصحيح الأخطاء
الكمية. حتى الآن رأينا بعض الأمثلة على شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بما في ذلك شفرة Shor ذات التسعة
qubit وشفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit وشفرة الخمسة qubit. وناقشنا أيضاً صياغة المُثبِّتات التي توفر
لنا أساساً رياضياً يمكننا من خلاله وصف وتحليل هذه الشفرات والعديد من شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية
الأخرى. الشفرات التي ذكرتها للتو مثيرة للاهتمام بلا شك وتمثل نقطة بداية طبيعية
لاستكشاف تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية. المشكلة هي أنها لا تتحمل إلا معدل أخطاء منخفض جداً.
تصحيح خطأ على qubit واحد من خمسة أو سبعة أو تسعة ليس سيئاً لكن على الأرجح كما نعتقد
سنحتاج لأن نكون قادرين على تحمل أخطاء أكثر بكثير من ذلك لجعل الحوسبة الكمية واسعة النطاق
حقيقة واقعة. في هذا الدرس سنلقي نظرة أولى على بعض بنيات شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية الأكثر تطوراً بما في ذلك شفرات يمكنها
تحمل معدل أخطاء أعلى بكثير مما رأيناه حتى الآن وتُعتبر مرشحة واعدة لتصحيح الأخطاء الكمية العملي في
الأجهزة الفيزيائية الفعلية. هنا نظرة عامة موجزة على الدرس. سنبدأ بفئة من
شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية تُعرف بشفرات CSS سميت على اسم الباحثين الذين اكتشفوها أولاً Robert Calderbank و Peter
Shor و Andrew Steane. بنية شفرة CSS تسمح بأخذ أزواج معينة من شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء
الكلاسيكية ودمجها في شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية. كجزء من هذا النقاش سنلقي
نظرة سريعة على الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية وسنتحدث أيضاً عن بعض الخصائص الأساسية لشفرات
CSS. الجزء الثاني من الدرس عن شفرة تُعرف بشفرة الطارة وهي مثال أساسي وجميل
حقاً لشفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية يمكنها تحمل معدل أخطاء مرتفع نسبياً. في الحقيقة
شفرة الطارة ليست مثالاً واحداً لشفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية بل هي عائلة لا نهائية من الشفرات واحدة لكل
عدد صحيح موجب بدءاً من اثنين. وفي الجزء الأخير من الدرس سنناقش باختصار عائلتين أخريين
من الشفرات الكمية بما في ذلك شفرات السطح المرتبطة ارتباطاً وثيقاً بشفرة الطارة بالإضافة إلى
شفرات الألوان. الناس يدرسون شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكلاسيكية منذ الأربعينيات
وهو مجال غني وممتع. الشفرات الخطية ربما تكون أبسط نوع من شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء
الكلاسيكية وسأشرح بالضبط ماذا تعني كلمة خطية في هذا السياق بعد لحظة. لكن طريقة بسيطة
للتعبير عما هي هو أنها شفرات مُثبِّتات تكون كلاسيكية. وسنرى قريباً أن
شفرات CSS هي أساساً أزواج من الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية تُدمج معاً لإنشاء شفرة تصحيح أخطاء
كمية. فمن أجل هذا النقاش سنحتاج لفهم بعض الأشياء الأساسية عن
الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية. أولاً سنأخذ sigma كالأبجدية الثنائية لهذا النقاش
بأكمله. والآن عندما نشير إلى شفرة خطية كلاسيكية نعني مجموعة C من السلاسل الثنائية بطول n لعدد
صحيح موجب n ما تحقق خاصية أساسية واحدة فقط وهي أنه إذا كان u و v سلسلتين ثنائيتين في C فإن السلسلة
u XOR v تكون أيضاً في C. هنا بالمناسبة u XOR v تعني العملية الحصرية بتات على u و v تماماً
كما رأينا عدة مرات في الدرسين الخامس والسادس في جزء الخوارزميات الكمية من السلسلة. وهذا ما يعنيه أن تكون
شفرة كلاسيكية خطية. في الأساس نحن نفكر في السلاسل الثنائية بطول n كمتجهات n-بعدية
حيث العناصر كلها إما صفر أو واحد لكن بدلاً من جمع المتجهات العادي على الأعداد الحقيقية أو المركبة
نستخدم الجمع modulo 2 وهو ببساطة XOR. فإذا كان لدينا
كلمتا شفرة u و v بمعنى أن u و v سلسلتان ثنائيتان في C فإن u زائد v modulo 2 أو بعبارة أخرى u XOR
v يجب أن تكون أيضاً كلمة شفرة في C. وبالمناسبة هذا الشرط يجب أن يكون صحيحاً حتى لو كان u يساوي v. لا شيء يمنع
هذا الاحتمال وهذا يعني أن كل شفرة خطية كلاسيكية يجب أن تحتوي على سلسلة الأصفار الكاملة لأن
XOR أي سلسلة مع نفسها هي سلسلة الأصفار الكاملة. مثلاً شفرة التكرار
بثلاثة بتات هي شفرة خطية كلاسيكية. بشكل خاص هناك اختياران ممكنان لـ u واختياران ممكنان
لـ v ومن البديهي جداً المرور على الأزواج الممكنة لنرى أننا نحصل دائماً على كلمة شفرة عند أخذ
XOR. هنا مثال آخر يُسمى شفرة Hamming ذات المعاملات [7,4,3]. هذه واحدة من أوائل شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء
الكلاسيكية التي اكتُشفت وتتكون من 16 سلسلة ثنائية بطول سبعة. هناك منطق بسيط جداً
وراء اختيار هذه السلاسل لكنني لن أشرح ذلك في هذا الفيديو. ويجب أن أذكر أيضاً أنكم قد ترون هذه السلاسل معكوسة أحياناً لكن
في الوقت الحالي النقطة الرئيسية هي أننا إذا أخذنا أي سلسلتين من هذه وعملنا لهما XOR معاً سنحصل على سلسلة أخرى في
الشفرة. فهي شفرة خطية. والترميز [7,4,3] بأقواس مربعة مفردة يعني شيئاً مشابهاً للأقواس
المربعة المزدوجة التي ذكرتها في الدرس السابق لشفرات المُثبِّتات لكن هنا للشفرات الخطية
الكلاسيكية. بشكل خاص كلمات الشفرة لها سبعة بتات وهناك 16 كلمة شفرة فيمكننا ترميز أربعة بتات باستخدام الشفرة و
يتضح أنها شفرة بمسافة ثلاثة بمعنى أنك تحتاج لقلب ثلاثة بتات على الأقل من أي كلمة شفرة للحصول على
كلمة شفرة مختلفة. وهذا يعني أنها تستطيع تصحيح خطأ قلب بت واحد على الأكثر. هذه أمثلة بسيطة على
الشفرات لكن حتى مثال شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] يبدو غامضاً نوعاً ما عندما نسرد كل كلمات الشفرة ببساطة. فنحتاج طرقاً أفضل
لوصف الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية. وهناك طريقتان طبيعيتان للقيام بذلك. إحدى الطرق هي وصف الشفرات الخطية
الكلاسيكية بإعطاء مجموعة دنيا من كلمات الشفرة التي تولّد الشفرة بمعنى أنه بأخذ كل المجموعات الجزئية
الممكنة من هذه الكلمات وعمل XOR لها معاً نحصل على الشفرة بأكملها. وهذا معبّر عنه بمصطلحات رياضية
هنا على الشاشة. طريقة أخرى للتفكير في هذا هي أننا ننظر لهذه الشفرة كفضاء جزئي من فضاء متجهي وهذه المجموعة
من المولدات هي أساس لذلك الفضاء الجزئي مع الأخذ بالاعتبار أن هذا فضاء متجهي حسابه modulo 2. إذا كان لدينا M مولد سينتج
لدينا شفرة بها اثنان أس M عنصر. كل مولد يضاعف عدد العناصر في الشفرة و
هذا يتسق مع حقيقة أن الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية على الأبجدية الثنائية تتضمن دائماً عدداً من السلاسل هو قوة
للعدد اثنين. الطريقة الطبيعية الثانية لوصف شفرة خطية كلاسيكية هي بفحوصات التكافؤ. تحديداً هذه قائمة دنيا
من السلاسل الثنائية بنفس طول السلاسل في الشفرة بحيث أن السلاسل في الشفرة هي بالضبط التي جداؤها
النقطي الثنائي مع كل سلسلة من سلاسل فحص التكافؤ يساوي صفراً حيث الجداء النقطي الثنائي هو ببساطة الجداء
الداخلي modulo 2. ومرة أخرى هذا شيء واجهناه في الدرس الخامس في سياق خوارزميات
الاستعلام. وسبب تسميتها بسلاسل فحص التكافؤ هو أن سلسلة معينة u جداؤها النقطي الثنائي يساوي
صفراً مع v إذا وفقط إذا كانت بتات u المقابلة للواحدات في v لها تكافؤ
زوجي. عندما نصف شفرة خطية كلاسيكية بهذه الطريقة بقائمة دنيا من سلاسل فحص التكافؤ كل سلسلة
فحص تكافؤ تقسم عدد السلاسل في الشفرة على اثنين. فلشفرة واحدة موصوفة بهاتين الطريقتين المختلفتين سيكون لدينا دائماً m زائد r يساوي
n. شيء مهم يجب ملاحظته هنا هو أن الجداء النقطي الثنائي ليس جداءً داخلياً بالمعنى الرسمي و
بشكل خاص عندما يكون الجداء النقطي الثنائي لسلسلتين يساوي صفراً فهذا لا يعني أنهما متعامدتان بالطريقة المعتادة التي نفكر بها عن
التعامد. مثلاً الجداء النقطي الثنائي للسلسلة 11 مع نفسها هو صفر. فمن الممكن أن
تكون إحدى سلاسل فحص التكافؤ هي نفسها في الشفرة. فهذا شيء يجب الانتباه
إليه. مثلاً كما نعلم بالفعل شفرة التكرار بثلاثة بتات هي شفرة خطية فيمكن وصفها بكلتا
الطريقتين. بشكل خاص هناك اختيار واحد فقط لمولد يعمل وهو 111. ويمكننا بديلاً وصف
الشفرة بسلسلتي فحص التكافؤ هاتين اللتين يجب أن تبدوا مألوفتين من مناقشاتنا السابقة لهذه
الشفرة. ولشفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] يمكننا استخدام هذه المولدات وفحوصات التكافؤ
هذه. وهنا بالمناسبة جميع سلاسل فحص التكافؤ تكون هي نفسها موجودة في الشفرة.
تعليق أخير عن الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية لربطها بصياغة المُثبِّتات: سلاسل فحص
التكافؤ هذه مكافئة لمولدات المُثبِّتات حيث لا نستخدم إلا مصفوفات Pauli Z والوحدة. مثلاً سلاسل فحص التكافؤ
110 و 011 لشفرة التكرار بثلاثة بتات تتوافق تماماً مع مولدات المُثبِّتات ZZ الوحدة
والوحدة ZZ. وهذا يتسق مع مناقشتنا للملحوظات من هذا النوع في الدرس
السابق. بعد ذلك سنناقش شفرات CSS وهي شفرات مُثبِّتات يمكن الحصول عليها بدمج أزواج معينة
من الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية التي لها نفس عدد البتات في ترميزاتها. هذا لا يعمل لأي شفرتين
خطيتين كلاسيكيتين فالشفرتان يجب أن تكون بينهما علاقة معينة كما سنرى قريباً. لكن مع ذلك هذه
البنية تفتح إمكانيات كثيرة لشفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بناءً جزئياً على ما تعلمناه من أكثر من 75 سنة من
نظرية الترميز الكلاسيكية. ذكرت سابقاً أنه في صياغة المُثبِّتات فإن مولدات
المُثبِّتات التي تحتوي فقط على مصفوفات Pauli Z والوحدة تكافئ فحوصات التكافؤ. مثلاً في شفرة التكرار
بثلاثة بتات يمكننا استخدام سلسلتي فحص التكافؤ 110 و 011 اللتين تفرضان أن البتين الأيسرين
متساويان والبتين الأيمنين متساويان لكل سلسلة في الشفرة. وهاتان السلسلتان تتوافقان تماماً مع مولدي
المُثبِّتات ZZ الوحدة والوحدة ZZ. لشفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] يمكننا استخدام
سلاسل فحص التكافؤ هذه وهي تتوافق مع مولدات المُثبِّتات هذه حيث نستبدل كل واحد بـ Z وكل صفر بالوحدة.
قد تتعرفون على مولدات المُثبِّتات هذه بالمناسبة لأنها ثلاثة من مولدات المُثبِّتات الستة لشفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit. وهذا
بالتأكيد ليس مصادفة وسنرى بالضبط ما يحدث هنا قريباً. سنسمي مولدات المُثبِّتات Z
لمولدات المُثبِّتات من هذا النوع بمعنى أنها تحتوي فقط على Pauli Z والوحدة كعوامل
تنسورية. فـ X و Y لا يظهران أبداً في مولد مُثبِّت Z. يمكننا أيضاً النظر في
مولدات مُثبِّتات حيث لا تظهر إلا مصفوفات Pauli X والوحدة. ويمكننا التفكير في مولدات المُثبِّتات من هذا النوع كمكافئة تماماً
لمولدات المُثبِّتات Z إلا أنها تصف فحوصات التكافؤ في أساس plus minus بدلاً من
الأساس المعياري. مثلاً بالعودة لشفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] يمكننا التفكير في
مولدات المُثبِّتات الثلاثة المتبقية من شفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit التي تتبع بالضبط نفس النمط كمولدات المُثبِّتات Z لهذه
الشفرة لكن هذه المرة نستبدل X بدلاً من Z للواحد. وما نحصل عليه من مولدات المُثبِّتات الثلاثة هذه فقط
هو شفرة تتضمن الحالات الستة عشر الموضحة هنا التي نحصل عليها بتطبيق بوابات Hadamard على حالات الأساس
المعياري المقابلة للسلاسل في شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3]. وبالطبع فضاء الشفرة يتضمن أيضاً
التركيبات الخطية لهذه الحالات. بطبيعة الحال مولدات المُثبِّتات من هذا الشكل تُسمى مولدات المُثبِّتات X.
فلا Y ولا Z مسموح بهما هذه المرة. والآن يمكننا تعريف شفرات CSS
بمصطلحات بسيطة: شفرات CSS هي شفرات مُثبِّتات يمكن التعبير عنها باستخدام مولدات مُثبِّتات Z
ومولدات مُثبِّتات X فقط. فلا Y مسموح بها ولا X و Z يظهران في نفس مولد
المُثبِّتات. وليكون هذا واضحاً يجب أن نضع في اعتبارنا أن هناك حرية في كيفية اختيار مولدات المُثبِّتات لشفرات
المُثبِّتات. وما يقوله هذا التعريف هو أن شفرة CSS هي شفرة يمكن فيها اختيار مولدات مُثبِّتات Z و X
فقط. لكن بشكل عام يمكنك اختيار مولدات مُثبِّتات مختلفة قد لا تكون مولدات مُثبِّتات Z أو X إذا أردت.
هنا تقريباً أبسط مثال غير بديهي لشفرة CSS حيث يوجد مولد مُثبِّت Z
ومولد مُثبِّت X. والتحقق من ذلك لا يحتاج أكثر من نظرة سريعة بالنظر إلى أننا نعلم من
الدرس السابق أن هذه شفرة مُثبِّتات صالحة. فضاء الشفرة أحادي البعد وهو الفضاء المولّد بحالة
Bell phi plus. ويمكننا ملاحظة أن مولدي المُثبِّتات يعملان بشكل تافه على هذا المتجه بالنظر إلى
التعبيرين لـ ebit الموضحين على الشاشة مع تفسير مولدات المُثبِّتات كفحوصات تكافؤ في أساسي 01
و plus minus. شفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit هي مثال آخر على شفرة CSS لأنه لهذا
الاختيار من المولدات لا نملك إلا مولدات مُثبِّتات Z و X. ونعلم مسبقاً أن هذه شفرة مُثبِّتات
صالحة. وشفرة Shor ذات التسعة qubit هي مثال آخر. هذه المرة لدينا ستة مولدات مُثبِّتات
Z ومولدا مُثبِّتات X فقط. وهذا مقبول فلا حاجة لتوازن أو تناظر
بين النوعين. لكن من الحرج أن تكون لدينا فعلاً شفرة مُثبِّتات صالحة وهذا يعني
أن كل مولد مُثبِّت Z يجب أن يتبادل مع كل مولد مُثبِّت X. فلا يمكنك
ببساطة اختيار النوعين من المولدات بشكل مستقل. وسأقول المزيد عن هذا لاحقاً في الدرس. بعد ذلك سنناقش اكتشاف
الأخطاء وتصحيحها لشفرات CSS. وما سنجده هو أن الخاصية التي لاحظناها في شفرة Shor ذات التسعة
qubit بأنه يمكننا اكتشاف وتصحيح أخطاء X وأخطاء Z بشكل مستقل تنطبق بشكل عام على شفرات CSS.
لشرح هذا أكثر لنأخذ شفرة CSS مثل شفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit لكن يمكن أن تكون شفرة CSS مختلفة إذا
أردتم. الفكرة الأساسية هي أن مولدات المُثبِّتات Z تكتشف أخطاء X
لكنها غافلة تماماً عن أخطاء Z لأن مولدات المُثبِّتات Z تتبادل دائماً مع أخطاء
Z. بالإضافة إلى ذلك مولدات المُثبِّتات Z تتبادل أيضاً مع أي بوابات Z قد نختار تطبيقها
كتصحيحات لأخطاء Z. وبالمثل مولدات المُثبِّتات X تكتشف أخطاء Z لكنها غافلة
تماماً عن أخطاء X والتصحيحات. فيمكننا في الأساس التفكير في مولدات المُثبِّتات Z كممثلة لشفرة
خطية كلاسيكية تحمي ضد قلب البتات أو بعبارة أخرى أخطاء X. بينما مولدات المُثبِّتات X
تمثل شفرة خطية كلاسيكية في أساس plus minus تحمي بشكل مستقل تماماً ضد الانقلابات
بين حالتي plus و minus أو بعبارة أخرى أخطاء قلب الطور أو أخطاء Z. فالآن يتضح تماماً ما يجري
مع شفرة Steane. إنها ببساطة شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] لأخطاء قلب البت وشفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] لأخطاء قلب
الطور. مرة أخرى حقيقة أن مولدات المُثبِّتات Z ومولدات المُثبِّتات X تتبادل مطلوبة فلن
تكون شفرة مُثبِّتات صالحة إذا لم تتبادل. ويمكنك القول إنه من حسن الحظ أن شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3]
تعمل هكذا. لكن هناك خيارات كثيرة أخرى يمكن أن تُتخذ لأزواج من الشفرات الخطية الكلاسيكية تعطينا شفرة مُثبِّتات صالحة
عند دمجها بهذه الطريقة. بالعودة لشفرات CSS بشكل عام لنفترض أن مولدات
المُثبِّتات Z تسمح بتصحيح ما يصل إلى J خطأ X ومولدات المُثبِّتات X تسمح بتصحيح
ما يصل إلى K خطأ Z. ففي حالة شفرة Steane كلاً من J و K يساوي واحداً لأن
شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] تصحح قلب بت واحد. لكن بشكل عام هذان العددان J و K يمكن أن يكونا مختلفين.
ينتج عندئذ بتكميم الأخطاء أن شفرة CSS تصحح أي خطأ على عدد من الـ qubit يصل إلى
الحد الأدنى بين J و K. وذلك لأنه عندما نقيس المتلازمة فإن خطأ عشوائياً على عدد
ما من الـ qubit ينهار احتمالياً إلى تركيبة ما من أخطاء X وأخطاء Z أو كليهما ثم
يمكن اكتشاف أخطاء X وأخطاء Z وتصحيحها بشكل مستقل. فطالما لدينا شفرتان
خطيتان كلاسيكيتان متوافقتان بمعنى أنهما تعطياننا مولدات مُثبِّتات X و Z تتبادل فإن
شفرة CSS التي نحصل عليها بدمجهما ترث أساساً خصائص تصحيح الأخطاء للشفرتين بالمعنى الذي شرحته
للتو. لاحظ أن هناك ثمناً يُدفع وهو أننا لا نستطيع ترميز عدد من الـ qubit بقدر ما نستطيع من البتات
مع الشفرتين الكلاسيكيتين لأن العدد الإجمالي لمولدات المُثبِّتات لشفرة CSS هو مجموع
عدد فحوصات التكافؤ للشفرتين الكلاسيكيتين وكل مولد مُثبِّتات يقسم بُعد فضاء الشفرة إلى
النصف. مثلاً شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] تسمح بترميز أربعة بتات كلاسيكية لأن لدينا فقط
ثلاثة فحوصات تكافؤ لهذه الشفرة بينما شفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit ترمز qubit واحداً فقط لأن لها ستة
مولدات مُثبِّتات. آخر شيء سأشرحه عن شفرات CSS بشكل عام في هذا الدرس يخص فضاءات الشفرة لشفرات CSS
وكيف تبدو. وهذا سيعطينا أيضاً فرصة لفحص العلاقة التي يجب أن تنطبق بين
شفرتين خطيتين كلاسيكيتين بمزيد من التفصيل لتكونا متوافقتين بحيث يمكننا دمجهما معاً لتشكيل شفرة
CSS. لنأخذ شفرة CSS عشوائية على N من الـ qubit ولتكن Z1 إلى Zs سلاسل فحص التكافؤ
ذات N بت المقابلة لمولدات المُثبِّتات Z. هذا يعني أن الشفرة
الخطية الكلاسيكية الموصوفة بمولدات المُثبِّتات Z والتي سنسميها CZ لمساعدتنا على تذكر أن
هذه الشفرة المقابلة لمولدات المُثبِّتات Z تأخذ الشكل الموضح هنا على الشاشة. بالكلمات الشفرة تحتوي كل
سلسلة u جداؤها النقطي الثنائي مع كل سلسلة من سلاسل فحص التكافؤ يساوي صفراً. لو أردنا يمكننا أيضاً
النظر في شفرة مختلفة مشتقة من نفس السلاسل والتي سنسميها DZ. والفكرة هنا هي أننا نفكر في
هذه السلاسل Z1 إلى Zs لا كسلاسل فحص تكافؤ بل كمولدات.
في هذه المرحلة ليس واضحاً لماذا نريد التفكير في هذه الشفرة لكن يمكننا ذلك وسيتبين أنها ذات صلة بهذا
النقاش. هذه الشفرة تُسمى الشفرة المزدوجة لـ CZ وتُرمز عادةً CZ عمودي بمعنى CZ مع رمز العمود
كأس علوي. لكننا سنسميها DZ وهذا سهل التذكر لأن D اختصار لمزدوجة
(dual). يمكننا أيضاً فعل شيء مماثل مع مولدات المُثبِّتات X. فهذه المرة CX هي الشفرة الخطية الكلاسيكية
التي سلاسل فحص تكافؤها تتوافق مع مولدات المُثبِّتات X و DX هي الشفرة المزدوجة لهذه الشفرة. كملاحظة جانبية
يمكننا الآن وصف الشروط التي يجب أن تنطبق حتى تكون CZ و CX متوافقتين بمعنى أننا نستطيع
إقرانهما معاً كشفرة CSS. بدلالة هذه الشفرات نفسها تحديداً يجب أن
تكون DZ محتواة في CX أو ما يكافئ أن DX محتواة في CZ. والآن من
الممكن وصف فضاء الشفرة لشفرة CSS المشتقة من هاتين الشفرتين. وإحدى طرق وصفه هي أنه
الفضاء المولّد بكل المتجهات التي تأخذ الشكل الموضح على الشاشة. بالكلمات تبدو كتراكبات منتظمة
على السلاسل في الشفرة المزدوجة DX للشفرة المقابلة لمولدات المُثبِّتات X مزاحة
بسلاسل في الشفرة CZ المقابلة لمولدات المُثبِّتات Z أو XOR معها. وسنرى كيف يبدو هذا
في الحالة الخاصة لشفرة Steane بعد لحظة. هذا منطقي لأن الحالات في فضاء الشفرة يجب أن تكون
متجهات ذاتية بقيمة زائد واحد لكل مولدات المُثبِّتات. وبشكل خاص الضرب بأي من مولدات المُثبِّتات
X يكافئ عمل XOR بالسلسلة X المقابلة. ولهذا تظهر هذه التراكبات المنتظمة
على DX مزاحة بسلاسل مختلفة بهذا الشكل. اختيارات مختلفة للإزاحة
الممثلة بالسلسلة y في هذا التعبير يمكن أن تعطينا نفس المتجه بالمناسبة. فهذه الحالات ليست كلها متمايزة لكنها مجتمعة تولّد
فضاء الشفرة بأكمله. هناك تناظر هنا بين مولدات المُثبِّتات X و Z و
الشفرات المقابلة لها. فيمكننا استخدام هذا التناظر لوصف المتجهات في فضاء الشفرة بطريقة مشابهة مع تبديل X و Z لكن
نحتاج أيضاً لتبديل الأساس المعياري بأساس plus minus ولهذا تظهر عمليات Hadamard في هذا
التعبير. الآن للمثال الموعود وهو شفرة Steane نحصل على هاتين الحالتين المرمزتين كترميزين ممكنين
لحالتي الأساس المعياري صفر وواحد. بشكل خاص يمكننا ترميز حالة الصفر كتراكب منتظم
على السلاسل الثمانية في الشفرة المزدوجة لشفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] والتي تكون نصف السلاسل في شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3]. و
يمكننا ترميز حالة الواحد بطريقة مماثلة إلا أن كل السلاسل تُعمل لها XOR بسلسلة الواحدات الكاملة. في هذه الحالة
لأن تلك السلسلة تكون في شفرة Hamming ذات [7,4,3] لكن ليست في الشفرة المزدوجة لها. تعليق أخير هنا هو أننا غالباً
لا نهتم كثيراً بشكل المتجهات في فضاءات الشفرة لأننا عموماً لا نحتاج لمعرفة ذلك لاستخدام
الشفرات. فإذا لم يكن هذا الشرح واضحاً فهذا ليس شيئاً يستحق القلق كثيراً. لكنه بالتأكيد
طبيعي أن نسأل كيف تبدو المتجهات في فضاءات شفرات CSS وهذا الوصف يقدم إجابة على ذلك
السؤال. بعد ذلك سنناقش شفرة CSS محددة تُعرف بشفرة الطارة وهي مثال على ما يُعرف بشفرة
تصحيح أخطاء كمية طوبولوجية. اكتُشفت هذه الشفرة على يد Alexei Kitaev في عام
1997. في الحقيقة شفرة الطارة ليست شفرة واحدة بل عائلة من الشفرات واحدة لكل عدد صحيح موجب على
الأقل اثنين. هذه الشفرات تمتلك بعض الخصائص الرئيسية. الخاصية الرئيسية الأولى هي
أن جميع مولدات المُثبِّتات لها وزن منخفض كعمليات Pauli. بشكل خاص كلها ستكون بوزن
أربعة. وهذا جيد لأنه يعني أن كل قياس لمولد مُثبِّتات لا يحتاج أن
يشمل عدداً كبيراً من الـ qubit. أحياناً يتحدث الناس عن شفرات LDPC الكمية أو شفرات فحص التكافؤ
منخفضة الكثافة الكمية. وهذا ما يُقصد بهذا المصطلح حيث "منخفض" يعني هنا أربعة. فشفرة الطارة مثال على شفرة
LDPC كمية. شفرة الطارة أيضاً لديها ما يُسمى الموقعية الهندسية بمعنى أنه ليس فقط
مولدات المُثبِّتات ذات وزن منخفض بل من الممكن أيضاً ترتيب الـ qubit مكانياً بحيث
يشمل كل قياس لمولد مُثبِّتات qubit قريبة من بعضها فقط مما يجعل هذه القياسات أسهل في التنفيذ
من حيث المبدأ. وأخيراً هذه الشفرات لها مسافة كبيرة فيمكنها تحمل معدل أخطاء مرتفع
نسبياً. إليكم كيف تعمل هذه الشفرات. أولاً ليكن L الكبير عدداً صحيحاً
موجباً على الأقل اثنين وننظر في شبكة L في L بحدود ما يُسمى دورية.
مثلاً هنا شبكة L في L حيث L يساوي 8. ولاحظ أن الخطوط
على اليمين وأسفل منقطة. والفكرة هنا هي أننا نريد التفكير في الخط المنقط على اليمين كأنه نفس الخط
الذي على اليسار. وبالمثل الخط المنقط في الأسفل هو نفس الخط الذي في
الأعلى. فإذا أردنا فعلاً تحقيق هذا الترتيب فيزيائياً سنحتاج ثلاثة
أبعاد. بشكل خاص يمكننا تشكيل أسطوانة بمطابقة الجانبين الأيسر والأيمن أولاً ثم ثني
الأسطوانة بحيث تلتقي الدائرتان في الطرفين اللتان كانتا الحافتين العلوية والسفلية للشبكة. أو يمكنك
مطابقة الأعلى والأسفل أولاً ثم الجانبين. كلتا الطريقتين تعملان ولا يهم أيهما تفعل لهذا
النقاش. ما نحصل عليه هو طارة أو بعبارة أخرى كعكة مع ثقب. رغم أن التفكير فيها كإطار داخلي لعجلة
قد يكون صورة أفضل لأن هذا ليس جسماً صلباً. الشبكة أصبحت فقط سطح
طارة. وهذا أصل تسمية شفرة الطارة. الطريقة التي يمكنك التنقل بها على
طارة كهذه بافتراض أنك تستطيع التنقل بين نقاط متجاورة على الشبكة ستكون مألوفة لمن لعبوا ألعاب فيديو قديمة
حيث إذا تحركت خارج الحافة العلوية للشاشة تظهر في الأسفل وبالمثل للحافتين اليسرى واليمنى
للشاشة. وفي معظم الأحيان هذه هي الطريقة التي سأصف بها هذه الشبكة بدلاً من التحدث تحديداً عن
طارة في فضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد. بعد ذلك نتخيل أن الـ qubit
توضع على حواف الشبكة كما هو موضح هنا على الشاشة حيث الـ qubit مُشار إليها بدوائر زرقاء
صلبة. لاحظ بالمناسبة أن الـ qubit الموضوعة على الخطوط المنقطة ليست صلبة وذلك لأننا مثلنا تلك الـ qubit
سابقاً بالموجودة على الحافة العلوية أو اليسرى. مع الأخذ بالاعتبار أن الخطوط في الأعلى واليسار هي بالضبط نفس الخطوط
المُشار إليها بالخطوط المنقطة في الأسفل واليمين. وإذا عددنا كل هذه الـ qubit نحصل على 2 ضرب L تربيع qubit. وإحدى
الطرق لرؤية ذلك هي ملاحظة أن لدينا L تربيع qubit على الحواف الأفقية و L تربيع qubit على الحواف
العمودية. فهذا ترتيب الـ qubit لدينا. ولوصف شفرة الطارة نفسها نحتاج فقط لوصف مولدات
المُثبِّتات وهناك نوعان منها. أولاً لدينا مولدات المُثبِّتات Z
وهذه تتوافق مع المربعات أو البلاطات في الشكل. وثانياً لدينا مولدات المُثبِّتات
X وهذه تتوافق مع الرؤوس في الشكل. فمثلاً هنا مولد
مُثبِّت بمعنى أننا نأخذ الجداء التنسوري لعملية Pauli Z واحدة لكل qubit تلامس هذه البلاطة مع مصفوفات الوحدة
على كل الـ qubit الأخرى. وهذا يعطينا عملية Pauli بوزن أربعة. وهنا مثال على مولد مُثبِّت
X حيث لدينا مصفوفات Pauli X تعمل على الـ qubit الأربع المتصلة بهذا الرأس مع
مصفوفات الوحدة على كل الـ qubit الأخرى. فمرة أخرى هي عملية Pauli بوزن أربعة. من المهم أنه لكلا
نوعي مولدات المُثبِّتات نُدرج تلك التي تلتف عند الحدود الدورية. وهنا مثال على مولد مُثبِّت X
يفعل ذلك. الآن من أجل الحصول على شفرة مُثبِّتات صالحة نحتاج لمولدات
المُثبِّتات أن تتبادل. مولدات المُثبِّتات Z كلها تتبادل مع بعضها لأن Z يتبادل مع نفسه والوحدة
تتبادل مع كل شيء. وبالمثل لمولدات المُثبِّتات X. ومن الواضح أيضاً أن مولد مُثبِّت Z ومولد مُثبِّت
X يتبادلان عندما يعملان بشكل غير تافه على مجموعات منفصلة من الـ qubit كالمولدين الموضحين
هنا. الاحتمال المتبقي هو أن مولد مُثبِّت Z ومولد مُثبِّت X يتداخلان و
كلما حدث ذلك يكون التداخل دائماً على qubit اثنتين فتتبادل مولدات المُثبِّتات لأن ZZ
و XX يتبادلان. الآن هذه ليست مجموعة دنيا من مولدات المُثبِّتات. بشكل خاص إذا ضربنا
كل مولدات المُثبِّتات Z معاً نحصل على الوحدة لأن كل qubit تُضرب بـ Z مرتين
مرة لكل بلاطة تلامس الـ qubit. هذا يعني أن ضرب كل مولدات المُثبِّتات Z معاً
ما عدا واحدة يعطينا تلك الأخيرة. فهي ليست مستقلة لكن إذا أزلنا أي واحدة منها نحصل على
مجموعة مستقلة. ونفس الشيء صحيح لمولدات المُثبِّتات X. فيمكننا إزالة واحدة من كل نوع
ولا يهم أيها نزيل. وهذا يترك L تربيع ناقص واحد مولد مُثبِّتات من كل نوع. لنكون
واضحين بشأن هذا وهو شيء ألمحت إليه في الدرس السابق: نحن فعلاً نهتم بكل مولدات المُثبِّتات هذه وبمعنى عملياتي
صارم لن نختار فعلاً واحدة من كل نوع لنتجاهلها. لكن من أجل تحليل الشفرة يمكننا
أن نتخيل أن مولد مُثبِّتات واحداً من كل نوع قد أُزيل حتى نحصل على مجموعة مولدة دنيا. مع الأخذ بالاعتبار
أننا نستطيع دائماً استنتاج نتائج هذه المولدات المزالة باعتبارها ملحوظات من نتائج كل مولدات المُثبِّتات
الأخرى من نفس النوع. فعدد الـ qubit التي ترمزها هذه الشفرة يساوي العدد الإجمالي
للـ qubit وهو 2 ضرب L تربيع ناقص العدد الإجمالي لمولدات المُثبِّتات في مجموعة مولدة دنيا وهو 2 ضرب L تربيع ناقص
واحد. وهذا يعني أنه يمكننا ترميز qubit اثنين. لم أبرهن بالمناسبة أن فضاء الشفرة غير تافه لكنه فعلاً
غير تافه. وسأترك لكم إقناع أنفسكم بأنه لا توجد طريقة لضرب مولدات المُثبِّتات معاً بطريقة تعطينا
سالب واحد ضرب الوحدة. فهذه هي شفرة الطارة نفسها. وعند هذه النقطة قد لا يكون
واضحاً أبداً لماذا يجب أن تكون هذه الشفرة جيدة لتصحيح الأخطاء الكمية. يبقى لنا تحليلها وما سنجده هو أنها في
الحقيقة شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية مذهلة. لفهم كيف تعمل شفرة الطارة كشفرة تصحيح أخطاء
كمية سنبدأ بالنظر في أخطاء مختلفة والمتلازمات التي تولدها. أول شيء يجب ملاحظته هو أن
شفرة الطارة هي شفرة CSS لأن كل مولدات المُثبِّتات إما مولدات مُثبِّتات Z أو مولدات مُثبِّتات
X. وهذا يعني أن أخطاء X وأخطاء Z يمكن اكتشافها وربما تصحيحها
بشكل منفصل. وفي الحقيقة هناك تناظر بسيط بين مولدات المُثبِّتات Z و X يسمح لنا بتحليل أخطاء
X وأخطاء Z بنفس الطريقة أساساً. فسأركز على أخطاء X التي تُكتشف بمولدات المُثبِّتات
Z. ويمكنكم ترجمة كل شيء لأخطاء Z التي تُكتشف بمولدات المُثبِّتات X باستخدام نفس
الأفكار تماماً. هنا شكل يوضح الـ qubit 2L تربيع على حواف شبكة L
في L بحدود دورية. ويمكننا تخيل أن هذا مرتب على سطح
طارة. في اللحظة الحالية كل الـ qubit زرقاء مما يشير إلى أنها qubit لم تتأثر
بأخطاء. فيجب أن تتخيلوا أنه في هذه المرحلة حالة هذه الـ qubit في فضاء الشفرة لهذه
الشفرة. كما ذكرت تركيزنا سيكون على أخطاء X وبعد لحظة سنستخدم دوائر بنفسجية للإشارة إلى qubit
تأثرت بأخطاء X. أخطاء X تُكتشف بمولدات المُثبِّتات Z المقابلة
للبلاطات في الشكل. فما يمكننا فعله هو جعل البلاطات البيضاء تشير إلى نتائج قياس زائد واحد أو بعبارة أخرى
عناصر في المتلازمة مقابلة لذلك المولد. بينما البلاطات الرمادية ستشير إلى نتائج قياس سالب
واحد. يمكنك التفكير في نتيجة زائد واحد أو بلاطة بيضاء كإشارة إلى أن مولد المُثبِّتات
المقابل سعيد. كل شيء يبدو على ما يرام لهذا المولد. بينما نتيجة سالب واحد أو بلاطة رمادية
تشير إلى أن مولد المُثبِّتات المقابل غير سعيد لأنه بوضوح حدث خطأ ما ليسبب هذه
النتيجة. ففي اللحظة الحالية كل مولدات المُثبِّتات سعيدة لأنه لم تحدث أخطاء. الآن إذا فكرنا
في مولد مُثبِّت Z فكل ما يفعله هو قياس تكافؤ الـ qubit الأربعة التي تلامس البلاطة بالنسبة
للأساس المعياري. فنتيجة زائد واحد لا تشير إلى أنه لم تحدث أخطاء X على هذه الـ qubit
الأربع بل تشير إلى أن عدداً زوجياً من أخطاء X حدث. بينما نتيجة سالب واحد تشير
إلى أن عدداً فردياً من أخطاء X حدث. والآن لندخل خطأ X ونرى ما
يحدث. مولدا المُثبِّتات Z المقابلان للبلاطتين اللتين تلامسان هذا الـ qubit أصبحا الآن غير سعيدين لأن
خطأ X هذا لا يتبادل مع كلا المولدين. أو بما يكافئ بدلالة الأساس المعياري نحن الآن في
حالة حيث مجموعتا الأربعة qubit المقابلتان للبلاطتين لهما تكافؤ فردي. فهذا تأثير خطأ X
واحد. فلو قسنا هذه المتلازمة وكنا نعلم أو نفترض أن خطأ X واحداً فقط حدث سنتمكن
من استنتاج أي qubit انقلب بسهولة ويمكننا ببساطة قلبه مرة أخرى ببوابة X. الآن لنرَ ما يحدث
عندما ندخل أخطاء X إضافية وبشكل خاص لنرَ ما يحدث عندما يحدث خطأ X ثانٍ على qubit
أخرى تلامس إحدى البلاطات الرمادية. لنقل البلاطة الرمادية في الأعلى
هكذا. تلك البلاطة أصبحت الآن سعيدة لأن خطأي X حدثا على الـ qubit التي تلامس هذه البلاطة واثنان زوجي. ف
هذان الخطآن X معاً يتبادلان مع مولد المُثبِّتات لهذه البلاطة. طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أن
خطأ X الثاني هذا أعاد حالات الأساس المعياري لهذه الـ qubit الأربعة من تكافؤ فردي إلى
زوجي. البلاطة على يسار خطأ X الجديد من ناحية أخرى أصبحت الآن غير سعيدة.
يمكننا متابعة هذه العملية بإضافة أخطاء X جديدة وطالما شكلنا سلسلة من أخطاء X متجاورة حيث متجاورة تعني أن الـ qubit تلامس
نفس البلاطة فإننا فعلياً ندفع نتيجة القياس سالب واحد حولنا. وما نجده هو أنه دائماً لدينا
نتائج قياس متلازمة سالب واحد عند نقاط نهاية سلاسل الأخطاء المتجاورة. فيمكننا دائماً اكتشاف سلاسل
أخطاء X المتجاورة طالما لها نقاط نهاية. قد تكون هناك بالمناسبة سلاسل متعددة لكننا سنعود
لهذا الاحتمال لاحقاً. من الممكن لكن أن تكون لدينا سلسلة من أخطاء X متجاورة
بدون نقاط نهاية بمعنى أن سلسلة الأخطاء قد تشكل حلقة مغلقة. فلنضف المزيد من الأخطاء
لتشكل حلقة مغلقة كهذه مثلاً. لدينا الآن عدد زوجي من أخطاء
X على كل بلاطة. فكل مولد مُثبِّتات الآن سعيد. وما وجدناه هو أن الحلقات
المغلقة من أخطاء X المتجاورة لا تُكتشف بهذه الشفرة لأننا نحصل على متلازمة كلها زائد واحد في هذه
الحالة. قد يبدو هذا مخيباً. في الحقيقة نحتاج فقط أربعة أخطاء X متجاورة لتشكيل حلقة مغلقة
ونحن نأمل في شيء أفضل من شفرة بمسافة 4. لكن بعض الحلقات المغلقة
من أخطاء X المتجاورة هي نفسها في المُثبِّت. تذكروا أن لدينا مولد مُثبِّت X لكل رأس في
الشبكة. وإذا ضربنا مولدات مُثبِّتات X متجاورة معاً يمكننا تشكيل حلقات مغلقة من عمليات
X كالتي لدينا هنا للحلقة المغلقة التي بنيناها قبل لحظات. فبعض الحلقات المغلقة من أخطاء X
كالموضحة هنا ليست أخطاء فعلاً أصلاً لأنها في المُثبِّت فلا تفعل شيئاً على الإطلاق لفضاء الشفرة. لكن هناك
بعض الحلقات المغلقة من أخطاء X ليست في المُثبِّت وبالتالي تمثل أخطاء غير تافهة تمر
بدون اكتشاف بالشفرة. وهناك طريقة بسيطة جداً لتوصيف الأنواع المختلفة من
الحلقات. الحلقات التي تقطع كل خط في الشبكة أي كل خط عمودي من الأعلى إلى الأسفل وكل خط أفقي
من اليسار إلى اليمين عدداً زوجياً من المرات هي دائماً جداءات مولدات مُثبِّتات X. هذا يشمل المثال
الموضح على الشاشة بالإضافة إلى حلقات قد تكون أكثر تعقيداً بما في ذلك احتمال أنها تقطع الحدود الدورية. لكن
مع ذلك بضرب هذه الحلقات المغلقة من أخطاء X بمولدات مُثبِّتات X يمكن فعلياً تقليصها إلى
لا شيء. ومن المؤكد بالمناسبة أننا لا نحصل على حلقات كهذه إلا بضرب مولدات مُثبِّتات X معاً لأن كل مولد مُثبِّت
X يضع عدداً زوجياً من عمليات X على كل خط أفقي وكل خط
عمودي. النوع الآخر من الحلقات المغلقة التي يمكن أن تكون لدينا هو حلقة تقطع خطاً واحداً على الأقل عدداً فردياً من المرات مثل
الموضحة هنا التي تقطع كل خط أفقي مرة واحدة فقط. وهنا مثال آخر يقطع
كل خط عمودي مرة واحدة فقط. فهذه أمثلة على أخطاء غير تافهة تمر بدون اكتشاف بالشفرة. لكن المفتاح
هنا هو أن الطريقة الوحيدة لتشكيل حلقة مغلقة كهذه هي الدوران حول الطارة إما حول الثقب في
وسط الطارة أو من خلال الثقب أو كليهما. هذه خاصية طوبولوجية
تخص الطارة. الأمر كله يتعلق بالثقوب أساساً. ولهذا تُسمى هذه شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية
طوبولوجية. بدلالة هذا التصور لشبكة ثنائية الأبعاد بحدود دورية يجب أن تلتف السلسلة في هذه الفئة
حول أحد الحدود الدورية أو كليهما بطريقة تجعل من المستحيل تقليص تلك الحلقة إلى
نقطة بضربها بمولدات مُثبِّتات X. قد تكون هذه السلسلة أكثر
تعقيداً من الموضحة هنا لكن هذا أقصر ما يمكن أن تكون عليه حلقة كهذه لأنها يجب أن تلتف بطريقة ما حول
أحد الحدود الدورية أو كليهما. وما يعنيه هذا هو أن الحد الأدنى لوزن خطأ غير تافه
لا يُكتشف هو L. أي حلقة مغلقة بأخطاء أقل من ذلك يجب أن تقع في الفئة الأولى وبالتالي تكون
في المُثبِّت. وسلاسل الأخطاء التي لا تشكل حلقات مغلقة تُكتشف بالشفرة. وهذا كل شيء. هذا سبب عمل هذه الشفرة.
وما نحصل عليه هو شفرة مُثبِّتات [2L تربيع، 2، L]. نستخدم 2L تربيع
qubit لترميز qubit اثنين والشفرة بمسافة L. بعد ذلك سأقول قليلاً عن
تصحيح الأخطاء بشفرة الطارة رغم أنني لن أدخل كثيراً في التفاصيل. إذا قسنا المتلازمة و
رأينا شيئاً غير متلازمة كلها زائد واحد وأنا أتحدث هنا عن مولدات المُثبِّتات Z فقط
فنتائج سالب واحد تشير لنا إلى نقاط نهاية سلسلة أو أكثر من أخطاء X المتجاورة. ويمكننا محاولة تصحيح
هذه الأخطاء بإقران نتائج سالب واحد معاً وتشكيل سلسلة من تصحيحات X بينها. وأثناء
قيامنا بهذا من المنطقي اختيار أقصر المسارات لتصحيحاتنا. مثلاً إذا قسنا
متلازمة كالموضحة هنا يمكننا اختيار هذا المسار بين البلاطات غير السعيدة وتطبيق بوابات
X كتصحيحات على هذا المسار. بالطبع السلسلة الفعلية من الأخطاء المسببة للمتلازمة قد تكون
مختلفة كالموضحة هنا. لكن هذا مقبول طالما أن الأخطاء والتصحيحات معاً
تقع في المُثبِّت. قد يكون أيضاً أن تصحيحاتنا تكمل حلقة حول
الطارة وهذا سيئ لأننا بذلك سببنا خطأ منطقي. فهذه الاستراتيجية بالتصحيح
على أقصر المسارات تصحح الأخطاء منخفضة الوزن لكنها قد لا تعمل للأخطاء عالية الوزن. لكن بالطبع لا يمكننا
أن نتوقع أكثر من أي شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية. الأرجح ربما حسب نموذج الضوضاء هو أننا
نلاحظ مجموعة من قيم سالب واحد في المتلازمة. وفي هذه الحالة يمكننا استخدام خوارزميات كلاسيكية فعالة لمساعدتنا
في إقرانها وإيجاد خطأ بأقل وزن يمثل المتلازمة. كما ذكرت في الدرس
السابق هذا قد لا يصحح دائماً التفسير الأرجح للمتلازمة لكنه يعمل بشكل جيد عموماً
وينجح دائماً في تصحيح الأخطاء ذات الوزن الأقل بشكل صارم من نصف المسافة L. ويجب أن أذكر أيضاً
أن هناك استراتيجيات أخرى أنسب لنماذج أخطاء مختلفة. مضى أكثر من 25 سنة منذ
اكتشاف شفرة الطارة وخلال تلك الفترة كان هناك الكثير من العمل على شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بما في ذلك
شفرات تصحيح أخطاء كمية طوبولوجية أخرى مستوحاة من شفرة الطارة بالإضافة إلى شفرات مبنية على أفكار
مختلفة. بالتأكيد لا أستطيع إعطاءكم قائمة شاملة بكل بنيات الشفرات المعروفة لكنني سأخدش السطح
قليلاً وأذكر باختصار مثالين معروفين. أولاً كما يتبين ليس
ضرورياً حقاً أن تكون لشفرة الطارة حدود دورية. أي أنه من الممكن قطع جزء فقط من شفرة الطارة و
وضعه مسطحاً على سطح ثنائي الأبعاد بدلاً من طارة. وما نحصل عليه بذلك يُسمى شفرة
سطح. مثلاً إذا قطعنا حواف شبكة بالنمط الموضح هنا بما يُسمى حواف خشنة في
الأعلى والأسفل وحواف ناعمة على الجوانب ونُدرج تبعاً لذلك حالات حدية لمولدات المُثبِّتات
فسنحصل على شفرة يمكنها ترميز qubit واحد فقط هذه المرة. لكن الشفرة مع ذلك ترث أهم
خصائص شفرة الطارة. بشكل خاص الأخطاء غير التافهة التي لا تُكتشف لهذه الشفرة يجب أن
تكون سلاسل أخطاء تمتد إما من الحافة اليسرى إلى اليمنى أو من الأعلى إلى الأسفل
حسب ما إذا كانت سلاسل أخطاء X أو Z على التوالي. من الممكن أيضاً قطع
الحواف بشكل مائل للحصول على ما يُسمى أحياناً شفرات سطح مُدارة. وفعل ذلك يمكن أن يساعد في جعل
الشفرات أكثر اقتصاداً من حيث عدد الـ qubit المستخدمة. مثلاً إذا أخذنا شفرة السطح
هذه وتخلصنا من بعض الـ qubit تاركين مربعاً موجهاً بشكل مائل نحصل على شفرة سطح
أخرى طالما حددنا مولدات المُثبِّتات على الحدود بالطريقة الصحيحة. مخططات كهذه
مفيدة لتوضيح كيف تُعرّف مولدات المُثبِّتات حيث البلاطات السوداء بما فيها المدورة عند الحواف تشير إلى مولدات مُثبِّتات X
والبيضاء تشير إلى مولدات مُثبِّتات Z. تلك الموجودة على الحدود بالمناسبة هي مولدات مُثبِّتات XX
أو ZZ على qubit اثنين هذه المرة. وسترون هذه المخططات عادةً مُدارة بزاوية
45 درجة. فئة أخرى مثيرة للاهتمام من الشفرات التي تقع أيضاً في الفئة العامة للشفرات الطوبولوجية هي شفرات
الألوان. لن أشرح بالضبط كيف تعمل لكن طريقة للتفكير فيها هي أنها تعميمات هندسية
لشفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit. فلنأخذ شفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit ولنفترض أننا نرقم
الـ qubit باستخدام ترتيب KCET كما هو موضح هنا على الشاشة. يمكننا عندئذ ربط هذه الـ qubit
السبعة برؤوس الرسم البياني الموضح هنا. وما نجده هو أن مولدات المُثبِّتات تتطابق
مع البلاطات أو الأوجه التي تتشكل من حواف الرسم البياني. ولكل بلاطة لدينا دائماً مولد مُثبِّت
Z ومولد مُثبِّت X يعملان بشكل غير تافه على بالضبط تلك الـ qubit الموجودة عند رؤوس تلك
البلاطة. هذا جميل لأنه تماماً كشفرة الطارة لدينا موقعية هندسية لهذه الشفرة فلا نحتاج
لنقل الـ qubit مسافات طويلة لقياس مولدات المُثبِّتات. وحقيقة أن مولدات المُثبِّتات Z و X تعمل دائماً بشكل غير تافه على
نفس مجموعات الـ qubit بالضبط هي أيضاً جميلة لأسباب تتعلق بالحوسبة الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء والتي سأقول عنها
المزيد في الدرس القادم. شفرات الألوان هي شفرات تصحيح أخطاء كمية تعمم هذا
النمط الأساسي حيث نفعل نفس الشيء أساساً لكن برسوم بيانية مختلفة. مثلاً هنا رسم بياني بـ
19 رأساً يعمل. هذا يعطينا شفرة ترمز qubit واحداً في 19 وتصادف أن مسافتها
خمسة. تُسمى شفرات الألوان بالمناسبة لأن أحد الشروط المطلوبة على الرسم البياني هو أن الأوجه يمكن تلوينها بثلاثة ألوان بمعنى
أنه يمكننا تلوين الأوجه بثلاثة ألوان بدون أن يتشارك وجهان بنفس اللون في حافة.
الألوان لا تهم فعلاً للشفرة نفسها فلدينا ببساطة مولدات مُثبِّتات X و Z لكل وجه بغض النظر عن لونه. لكن الألوان
تتبين أنها مهمة لتحليل كيفية عملها. فهاتان عائلتان معروفتان جداً
من الشفرات. لكن هناك بنيات كثيرة أخرى معروفة بما فيها مبنية على أفكار مشابهة لهذه العائلات بالإضافة إلى
أخرى مختلفة تماماً. مثال محدد على شفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية اكتُشفت مؤخراً
من قبل بعض زملائي في IBM تُعرف بشفرة الغروس وسميت كذلك لأن الغروس هو اثنا عشر
دزينة أو 144. بشكل خاص هذه الشفرة ترمز 12 qubit في 144 qubit ومسافتها
12. لن أشرح كيف تعمل هذه الشفرة بالتفصيل. هي مشابهة لشفرة الطارة إلا أن كل مولد
مُثبِّتات يشمل الآن qubit إضافيتين أبعد قليلاً. ليس لها تضمين مستوٍ
مثل شفرة السطح لكن لها ما يُسمى تضميناً ثنائي المستوى بمعنى أن طبقتين من الـ qubit مطلوبتان بدلاً
من واحدة. تقع ضمن عائلة شفرات تُسمى شفرات الدراجة ثنائية المتغيرات. والمذهل بشأنها بشكل خاص هو
أنها أكثر كفاءة بكثير من شفرة الطارة أو شفرة السطح بمعنى أن qubit أكثر بكثير يمكن ترميزها وفي الوقت نفسه
تتحمل تقريباً نفس معدل الأخطاء. لشفرة الغروس يُحتاج 144 qubit إضافية لقياس
المتلازمة فالعدد الإجمالي للـ qubit المطلوبة هو 288 مما يجعلها مرشحة واعدة جداً لتقنية
اليوم. وبهذا يُختتم هذا الدرس الذي كان عن بنيات شفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بما في ذلك شفرات CSS وشفرة الطارة و
لمحة عن بنيات شفرات كمية أخرى بما في ذلك شفرات السطح وشفرات الألوان. أتمنى أن تنضموا إليّ في
الدرس القادم والأخير من السلسلة عن الحوسبة الكمية المتسامحة مع الأخطاء والذي يتناول تحدي إجراء
الحسابات على حالات كمية مرمزة باستخدام عمليات ومكونات حوسبة هي نفسها عرضة
للأخطاء. إلى اللقاء.